here we go in five four three two one
what's up you [ __ ] stupid ugly people
bet you woke up looking like trash but
not to me because you're beautiful and
if your mother never told you that you
were talented I also agree welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast we're a podcast about everything
and anything and most podcasts typically
they just have a bunch of just random
celebrities they don't know I like to
bring in my friends because my friends
have great stories and great insight for
everybody who needs it out there today
we have a very special guest summer have
you ever done the podcast before um no
I've not not really
I've been on one show like a radio show
podcast yeah I was a podcast but it was
an I wasn't the subject of like what was
it for uh it was my friend's podcast and
he Dave Navarro he has like a thing that
he does and he interviews like artists
um he was interviewing this actor who I
was friends with and then because he
knew that I know him he was like why
don't you just come and watch and then
when I went to go watch he was like you
just come and sit down and I was like
yeah I don't want to [ __ ] do that oh
you know what and then that was the only
thing I've done I don't even remember
how I met you we met through weight but
you do Danielle you met me through
Danielle who I met through Lawrence and
you guys needed someone for one of your
videos and it was with like Coco Lee if
I think which video was that I can't
remember I feel like I've done so many
things with you it was was it the one
either when you're in a Superman early
spider-man suit or it's got working or
it's the the hot like that yeah that's
the one right Oh was it the one it was
it was at the South Pasadena spot and
then it was a very small scale
it was small I had like one line and it
was me thinking you know what the the
best one was that was the zombie sketch
- man that [ __ ] was so hard to get
through this woman would not stop
laughing it was so hard for me to get
through those [ __ ] lines that's
actually probably my top three favorite
things I've ever done that was rough you
were killing me that was ruining the
shoot through in the [ __ ] morning
laughing yo the first time I ever work
with Kunal I had him played dhalsim from
Street Fighter because he's like the
only Indian cat that I know I was like I
was like no I know this might be a
little offensive but I need you to play
a Indian character from Street Fighter
News also he's like you would [ __ ]
pick me for this [ __ ] but he's so
[ __ ] funny one of the funniest people
I've ever known so I guess that was the
first time he's ever worked with me and
then he didn't realize just how hard it
is sometimes to be in a scene with me
because of how it's stupid it gets and
you know my writing is really dumb I
know I can't stop laughing
he was just cracking up through every
[ __ ] take it's so hard not to laugh
it's so fun it's like the funnest night
but like I start feeling bad for the
camera person
I gotta breathe there are times in when
we're working in the keep we can hear
the [ __ ] camera guy giggle I'm fine
not to laugh I'm like I know it's hard
bro but here you [ __ ] laugh it's been
pretty crazy ya know I didn't know until
not that longer that you were previously
married yeah I was [ __ ] crazy
I know yeah we were married for almost
four years and then together for eight
12 [ __ ] years well no no no totally
hole of eight yeah oh sorry I'm the only
Asian person that can't do math it was
[ __ ] embarrassing
she was so [ __ ] embarrassing and
everybody's gonna give me [ __ ] about
that like no David it's [ __ ] you know
what I hate to when people put up these
memes they're like - parentheses 5/5
file what's that and everybody has the
wrong answers I'm the wrong answer and I
I don't even answer I wait for everybody
else to answer first and then I write my
response you guys are so dumb is this
answer no clue - it was embarrassing
yeah so 17 years it's been 24 years 24
years eight [ __ ] years so so yeah and
it's been over two years that we've been
divorced now how does that feel I mean I
always man I can't admit like I told
this to Muriel I say dude we've been
together for five years now if you
believe me if you [ __ ] leave me I
will die had that on your conscience
good night sweetie so do I want to kill
myself what did you did you that was it
a mutual breakup or do you guys um it
was mutual in the end what happened was
he he was the one that we had been back
and forth on and off like yeah um we
separated before that happened for a
while and then we decided to work on it
again and that happened a few times
throughout the time we were together he
had initiated at this time that last
time and he had just said it during this
like argument we were having and I my
brain was like he had never left I was
always the one that said I don't think
we can do this anymore it's just not
cool it's at the end of the day you're
who you are I am Who I am and it's like
forcing people to be someone that
they're not yeah so when he said it I
like iyx my brain exploded I was
devastated for like an hour and then I I
went to my girlfriends my girlfriend's
house and and just like under I just
like calm down and I it was what was
best he had finally he was finally able
to admit it to himself as well which is
which was important because what
happened was every time we would break
up it was like him wanting to prove that
it could change and there was um there
was you could change
yeah it was it was kind of like that but
I had a lot like I had all of my equal
parts to everything that made it
impossible for us to be together but it
was always like him you know telling me
trying to convince me that it could be
different and so when he said when he
said like we just can't be together
anymore that I think felt so final
because it was because it was finally
him and understanding like I was kind of
right those other times when I kept
saying but we just can't keep doing this
when did you guys first get to that
point though because it was it was an
eight-year relationship so like I mean
we there were a lot of there were a few
different points every time we broke up
it was twice before we got married and
then once we had gotten separated while
we were married every time that happened
it was for me I just felt like I don't
understand how we can keep moving
forward the issues were based on who we
were as people like our value systems
how we communicate to each other how we
treat each other and to me it felt at a
certain point like we were just kept
trying for I don't know what reason it
was hard to give up but I knew like I
think the last year two years at the end
of our relationship was really like a
force for both of us we were both that's
a weird place to be in because I know
I'm pretty sure a lot of people out
there know about sometimes it's it's
hard to break up because it feels like
you're giving up exactly and that's what
I never wanted to do I he had done you
know so much for me and was there for me
at like one of the hardest times in my
life that to me I just felt like how can
I let this go like that's how I looked
at it the last time we were trying
is there's no after everything he's done
for me that was my mentality at the time
how can i how can I leave him we have to
figure it out
so upon reflection after we I had the
day that he had told me he wanted a
divorce and I like how to break down and
then I went back to the house like a few
hours later and I was like okay like
let's okay I got it I agree I wanted to
be as amicable as possible because it
can get ugly fast and I didn't want that
and we were on the same page about that
but upon reflection with that I just I
don't know it was definitely for the
best and yeah Pam asked that's kind of
crazy cuz I can't imagine putting
yourself through that last few years
right because it's just it must be like
must feel like you're in limbo yes
because it's you're with this person but
you don't want to be but you should
because you have this certain sense of
loyalty because of what he helped you
through in the past so you're just going
back and forth constantly Mahad are you
how do you deal with that [ __ ] cuz I'm a
very just kind of like I didn't want to
be with him it was more like I was like
how much can I deal with like you know
he's he parties a lot so it was like how
much like for instance like that's like
one example of like something one of our
huge differences so like how much can I
deal with that like I need to just
accept that this is a part of who he is
and and and stop fighting against it but
at a certain point you make allowances
that go against your value system and I
think that's where I was struggling the
most and it wasn't fun like it wasn't
it's weird like you're it's you we
wouldn't there wasn't a lot of great
communication towards the end or any
really and there was a lot of you know
contempt which is really unhealthy and
there's a there's a hard part right
there too because I just talked to a
friend yesterday I'm over here mister
counselor but I just talked to a friend
yesterday because he split up with his
girlfriend right
and you know typically what happens is
when you go through these conversations
they'll say things and you kind of pick
apart what they're saying right so he
mentioned something where along the
lines of his girlfriend she likes to
party a lot and he mentioned a couple
times he goes but it doesn't bother me
and I like well hold on a second dude
within this conversation you mentioned a
few times that she goes out partying and
it doesn't bother you if it didn't
bother you you would have never
mentioned it to me
it does bother you yeah and I was like
the the problem is is that you I think
he doesn't want to be the controlling
boyfriend right he doesn't want to be
put in that light and he doesn't want to
give that reason to them to throw it
back in his face so for him it's like oh
no I'm cool with it but I was like see
you're not cool with it though that's
something that's fundamentally something
that bought it that isn't who you are
you're not a partying person you don't
like the people that she hangs out with
you don't like this done this is
something that you should be able to
discuss openly and if it's a breaking
point for you there's no way that you're
gonna be able to swallow this big pill
every [ __ ] no so it kind of came to
head for him yeah and he's gonna go back
and talk to her about it
yeah because it does bother him because
I guess for her she kind of travels and
does her own thing without him with her
own bunch of friends who he says it's
not really her friends that's like her
party friends and so he goes I don't
even know them
they're not really your friends you're
going out on these trips that you're not
even paying for who's paying for these
trips and I'm just supposed to be okay
with it he goes yeah I guess I'm okay
no it's never I guess I'm okay are you
okay with it or are you not yeah that's
it that's what I mean when I say like
when you get into a relationship you
make allowances because you you're their
[ __ ] completely different human being
than you so what are you okay with what
are you not okay with and at a certain
point sometimes before you've done a lot
of work on yourself
I think you'd people tend to make
allowances for certain behaviors or
patterns that go against their value
system but they're not able to really
register that that's what's happening
until you're a year down the line and
it's eating at you you know it takes
time for those things to to have the
effect that it will eventually have on
you and by that point you're this far
along into the relationship so it's like
how am I going to
I can give us up now why not put more
work into it but that's why I think it's
so important to have done the work on
yourself yeah before entering a
relationship so that you can know if
what you're okay with and what you're
not okay with at the at the base level
of who you're bringing into your life
and yeah yeah for sure I call those
things how I describe it to people I
always ask them I was like what are your
pillars and they go well we're two
pillars I was like pillars other things
that hold up your foundation those
things should never shift right and if
they if they shift that foundation then
that might be something that you can't
really compromise for I was like find
out what what are the things that you
will never compromise for yeah and for
me I have those things she never touches
those things were completely fine right
other than that everything else is just
fighting arguments and bickering but the
fundamental basics of Who I am are not
touched and then she respects that and
she loved those parts about me then
generally I think that you anybody will
be okay yeah right and so for him in his
case was he wants to be with somebody
that likes to share life experiences
with him that they're allowed to have
separate friends and he wants her to
have friends and go out but when it
comes to traveling and those the free
time he would like for her to spend that
with him just so they could develop that
part he wants somebody to travel with
yeah and all the time that she's
traveling it's not with him and he's
waiting at home and it's like well
that's something that you want big
that's a big [ __ ] thing it's a big
thing for someone like him yeah who
wants who that's like a part of it's
like the opposite of what exactly he's
just like no I think I'm okay you're not
okay with it dude if you say you think
you're okay or not okay there's
definitely things that I like she knows
for me it's like there's like definite
that I have does she for me like for
example even though it may not seem I'm
hyper religious but like I do want to
have somebody with Christian values even
if let's say later on the lives like I
don't really like going to church I like
Christian values a lot I think that's
always why I'm a shot somebody
so I for me is you know I'm like I I
think Jesus helps me out a bit so I
think I would like for my kids to have a
little Jesus in their lives you know why
the [ __ ] not so the kid can figure out
if he wants Jesus in his life later on
yeah that's all up to him but I just
want to at least instill those Christian
values cuz just for me growing up I know
a lot of dudes that were pieces of [ __ ]
and they don't believe in God now but
they kept a lot of their Christian
values you know loyalty community having
open communication not being afraid to
show love and I learned a lot of that
from church so I think that's what I
really enjoy about it so that's
definitely one number two is a strong
family ties is really understanding how
important family is
yeah cuz if you can't be respectful to
your parents you're not gonna be
respectful to mine and you're not gonna
be our relationship might be a little
off because I think as I got older when
I was younger I remember my dad told me
he goes you need to be with somebody
that understands what a good family is
and my mind I'm like - you just don't
like broken people huh you [ __ ]
judgmental [ __ ] you know that's what I
would say to them and as I get older I
start to realize that there are things
that happens to somebody at a young age
that they don't know how to address and
they don't realize how it affects him as
an adult that's basically what my dad
was saying he just said it in a very
terrible way and I'm starting to find
that out now a lot of my friends who do
come from broken homes not just broken
homes just terrible situations growing
up it affects them as an adult and they
can't they can't see it but everybody
else does like being in a family
sometimes where and you know like I said
if you don't grow up with like two
parents in the household but if you see
a healthy relationship um your uncle
your aunt there's a there are those but
there's some people who just don't see
any of that [ __ ] they don't see it from
close siblings like their uncles aunts
their cousins or whatever and they don't
know what that healthy relationship is I
see it a lot in my female friends who
have this certain perception of what men
like male machismo is like what a man
should be and they think this is my case
once again my personal friends they're
like I want somebody to always take care
of me guys have to do this this is what
a man is but what are you basing that on
who was that who was the man in your
life in your household that showed you
that this was a man was or is and that's
just a reoccurring theme that I see a
lot
or a thought the kid without a mom they
don't understand how to nurture they
don't know how to be emotionally
available because the dad was the tough
guy yeah everything is I have to be
tough I can't cry [ __ ] your feelings I
think the it's possible because I can
come from like I've very broken like
family situation I really didn't realize
it I mean it's definitely possible to
come from that and then work on it sure
come out it as long as you recognize it
but you have to recognize yeah I think
that was like a huge in the end when I
look back on the my marriage like that
that whole relationship it now is a huge
mirror back to me as far as like what I
needed to work on and the effects that
all of my past and childhood and stuff
was having on me and in a completely
negative way and what I was the things I
would wouldn't take responsibility for
and so since then putting the folks back
to myself I think I actually started
that after we had gotten separated yeah
when I went into therapy that it takes a
lot of work but it's possible for
someone to come from that situation and
then kind of turn it around Oh a hundred
percent it's a [ __ ] lot of work and
it's really hard yeah and I think the
biggest difference is that you you
recognize it right and just like anybody
else as long as you recognize your
faults there's a possibility that you
can work on it yeah I think with a few
people that I know it's it's hard for me
to bring it up to them and if I do I'm
the enemy so I just don't even touch it
it's like what's the whole point like if
I if I tell you like hey you're I think
as a friend that what's happening here
with your relationship is that you have
a very skewed perspective of what a man
or a woman should be in a relationship
and it might be because you had a really
rough life and you're damaged from that
and people are paying for the stuff that
you paid for as a kid mm-hm and that
stuff constantly projects out people
don't even [ __ ] know it like when I
when I first started going out with
Muriel she had this thing where she
didn't know how to express her anger and
it used to piss me the [ __ ] off because
it comes out passive-aggressively
I [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] because I'm
expressive right so if I'm upset I try
to figure out how to say it sometimes it
may not come out in the best way but I'm
always honest with my feelings yeah uh
she's not like that anymore she's a
little too expressive I opened a
Pandora's box and I [ __ ] up so now so
I remember this is like a very specific
example she would do some [ __ ] that
would piss me off because I could tell
that she's clearly upset right yeah and
she would do this [ __ ] where I would be
asking her hey I know you're upset she
goes oh I'm not upset
would you say it like that my blood
boils like a kettle was put in the
center of the Sun I was I'm like okay
when you say it like that
you're started I'm not mad at all are
you mad where's it where's the rifle I'm
gonna shoot this woman in the [ __ ]
face and I'm like listen when you're
upset it's okay we just gotta talk it
out be upset she goes I'm not mad and
then and then she's like passing out
like okay we'll pass the salt right and
then she just and slide it over I'm like
oh you're not mad you just took all the
lacquer off the [ __ ] table when you
slid that little salt pepper shakers
thank you son of a [ __ ] and so she
would she would just do a
passive-aggressive [ __ ] like that and
her anger would come out this way and I
remember at one time we were in the car
and we went on a hike and is this is
something that I really hated about her
early on was that she would do things
she was such an independent woman she
would just do everything everything on
her own accord and not wait for me Sofer
on hot if we're hiking she would walk
like a thousand paces ahead of me and
works also hiked together and mind you I
was [ __ ] fat leave no fat man behind
I think that was in the Bible and so I'm
just trailing behind her and then she's
just cool with it I'm like yo I want you
to walk at my pace like walk at my pace
and I got [ __ ] pissed and then we
were in the car I was like you're upset
because of what I said she goes I'm not
mad and I'm like dude when you're I was
like if you're I'm mad now I'm like if
you're [ __ ] mad just say you're mad
she turns at me and this is the center
console of the car she goes boom boom
boom and I looked at I said oh my bad oh
[ __ ] my bad
I didn't I didn't mean okay I don't know
it was like that ever since then she's
been hyper expressive and I regret that
moment till this day but the funny thing
is I and all jokes aside I rather have
that than having to deal with a pissy
ass person for the whole day no passive
is so unhealthy and that's how I that
was like one of my many flaws and my
last really the in my marriage like that
was it was now when I think about it I'm
mortified about the new face to do I
mean I've worked on it and it's very not
really there and I know how to catch it
and yeah and hold myself responsible in
the moment to kind of get out of
whatever pattern or behavior I'm getting
into but that shit's like it's super and
it's unbelievably unhealthy to be
passive-aggressive oh for sure like
communication is always key just
learning how to talk things out and
there's this balance that sometimes
people forget of how to be really
affirmative with their words without
being aggressive yeah yeah and also
express communicating without assigning
meaning to because when someone upsets
you and you're trying to communicate
what's going on for you with it you have
to do it without assigning meaning to
their behavior suck at that [ __ ] it's
because you know why would you [ __ ]
do it [ __ ] asses ask questions like
it's a command I don't even know how you
do it it's like oh so you're just gonna
leave the garbage that's right hold on a
second are you asking me to take out the
trash are you trying to fistfight me
right now cuz I will [ __ ] we will put
on gloves and we'll go
that's how Muriel does [ __ ] she goes oh
so we're just going to leave the air
conditioning on all day that's cool are
you what is this what was going on here
just tell me to turn it off pretty much
good to go
girls are so good at that [ __ ] and it
just gets under my skin
she's so cute and I'm just like oh dude
but we she still does that till this day
like it just bothers me but then I
always joke about it so we
man or like do you like snapback no now
it just turns into jokes because not
it's not enough to get me actually angry
anymore so I like she just did that
yesterday
should we forgot oh she had a dream this
is this is some crazy she get mad at you
for something she dreamed she got mad
about so I couldn't figure out why she
was so mad at me
and I might what the [ __ ] that I do I
just woke up like I literally just
breathed life two seconds ago well how
can I be what have I done
what have I done but she was cleaning up
the house and you know it was something
small where she goes she looks at me and
she goes so you use two cups mmm there's
some meaning behind that I'm like yeah I
just used 2 cups she goes cool could you
try after you're done using your cups to
put it in the dishwasher I'm like oh she
trying to get socked what did I do and
then you know just joking around I look
at I'm joking around like hey you don't
[ __ ] talk to me like that woman being
cute and joking about it and she goes no
you ought to just put away your cups and
I'm like what's the [ __ ] stuff right
now I'm gonna take it outside and then
she goes oh I had a terrible dream I'm
like that's it I knew it there's
something wrong she had a dream that I
was pregnant and I was gonna give birth
and she wasn't ready to have a child but
I was ready to have it that's why she
was mad at me cuz I was pregnant in her
dream something that's not [ __ ]
physically possible she was mad at me
for forgetting knocked up war [ __ ] who
knocked me up you did in that dream
you're the one who stuck your dirty
penis inside my butt I actually don't
know how was done I don't know I think I
think that's how kids are made you stuck
your filthy little button now I'm having
this child and you want to give it up
you [ __ ] bum yeah so she was mad at
me for for having a marine pregnant for
getting knocked up because I didn't I
don't know I must have poked a hole in
her condom or something in a dream and
she was mistreating me all day that [ __ ]
always gets me too and there's this
other time where this is probably gonna
last
it wasn't really a big fight but I was
pretty upset we're welcome in the
morning same thing I woke up and it's
just all help
and she's just mumbling to herself just
[ __ ] and she hates clutter right so
this is as cluttered as the apartment
guess it's very clean and so we I forgot
what we did but the apartment was a
little messy and we both agreed the
night before that we were going to leave
it alone shut off the lights and clean
it together in the morning well she woke
up earlier than I did and so she's just
stomping around and she's being [ __ ]
mean and I come into the room and she's
just like mumbling and you know talking
[ __ ] about me and I'm like the [ __ ] yeah
I want a go okay and I lightly close the
door right she come back out she goes
thanks for slamming the door in my face
and I just had it up to [ __ ] here
because I just woke up I'm like I need
to wake up before you fight yeah I look
bitter and I just come into the room I'm
whoa what's the problem as she goes
you're just over here just slamming door
I was like nope what is the problem she
goes no you slammed the door my face I
was like what is the actual [ __ ]
problem what is the problem and I'm so
mad I'm banging my chest like a [ __ ]
gorilla I'm like what is the problem
it's not that what is the actual issue
that you are dealing with right now
tearing up okay now things start to make
sense I would [ __ ] love for a pill to
be invented for a man to have to take so
that he could feel what it's like to PMS
and then to be on my period it is
completely out of our control what is
happening I hurt my own feelings all the
time I'm in bed like literally just in
bed thinking about something I'm like
this is a hundred percent my life like
everything's going right and I'm like
everything is [ __ ] in the gutter no
one loves me
I'll go it's unbelievably uh not like
out of our control I I completely agree
because I've learned to give those I
call those grace days like
that's I'm like I'm just gonna buy faith
and grace I'm going to internalize that
you calling me a fat [ __ ] was simply
your vagina topic
it was simply your ovaries exploding in
there and I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
let it go I have to because she knows
it's wrong but she has to say something
it's like you have to say that's why I
in my last relationship I would say
something like I'm gonna apologize
immediately but I need to say this I'm
really sorry
yeah we're over here like crying - I
know I know cuz you know why cuz it
makes you guys feel better that we're in
pain as well yeah it's like oh you're in
pain well guess what my [ __ ] has blood
all day how about that
- it's scary when you like get into new
relationship and you're like okay gotta
like work on work on this and and try
not you know what the most difficult
[ __ ] is is that there's no winning for a
guy in this because you're so emotional
you need emotional support so you kind
of want us there but at the same time
you don't want us there because he wants
to shut the [ __ ] up but still say stuff
to comfort you cuz my other thing was
before I found a girl that I really
cared about I would just disappear
I would disappear like a deadbeat dad I
would just be gone I'm like oh period
I'll see you in three days
oh god but with her she's just like oh
just gonna you know this is a life thing
right until I stop having just gonna
leave whenever you want
I guess I'll stay here would you like
some water why because I look dry in the
face no you look fine like you know you
don't need water Oh cuz water is like
[ __ ] for life you want me to [ __ ]
die okay excuse me and I get the shotgun
and I put it right to my bro I try to
[ __ ] somehow hit the trigger and the
blast the [ __ ] shotgun shell my ass
[ __ ] man I didn't realize that cuz she's
my first longest relationship yeah
everything else was short and we were
such a long distance I could just not be
there if I do that's so it's hard about
like getting into a relationship or you
realize the stuff that you have - oh
it's [ __ ] true and like got like like
every time you get into up into a new
you [ __ ] a new issue that's like
especially when you're first doing
something like that like your first
[ __ ] experience with her period or
whatever you're just like okay I gotta
like if I wanted this I can't let this
stop me from showing up for her oh for
sure like it's you know what it is it's
[ __ ] death and okay I have never been
in a situation where I was just like I
just can't escape yeah that's what
happened when when Marilyn I first moved
in together I was so used to having my
own place that when [ __ ] got crazy I
just go you know what I'm gonna bounce
and I'll come back tomorrow I'll talk to
you when you're level-headed and we got
into this huge fight this is the first
time that we moved this is about a year
ago and I was like probably the last big
fight that we had and I remember like a
five-year-old I said I'm out and I
grabbed my bag and I put my [ __ ] in it
and I looked at her and she looked at me
she owes where are you going I was like
I'm home
she goes what do you mean I'm like I
have nowhere to go this is my house I
started having an entire day attack I
was I started having it I was like okay
I can't go anywhere
what am I going yeah this is where you
live I'm like I know I got nowhere to go
so I'm just holding my back like a
little [ __ ] five-year-old terrifying
yeah I'm sticking my head do you think
since how old are you I am now 32 32 31
30 23 to Nestor okay
all right do you think before Marielle
did you feel like you had commitment
issues
oh definitely yeah I was it was easy for
me to just bounce just because like
anything that would happen that would
make you uncomfortable and I'm feeling
me you didn't want to feel you're like I
don't need to feel this I'm gonna oh no
it wasn't like that it was more mm we're
not compatible like this does not right
and now I would recognize it pretty
quick right uh I think that happened
because my very first relationship I was
trying to force this is when I was 18 I
was trying to force things that just
wouldn't fit you know so and I just made
it
a point to never do that again right any
relationship that I had after that so
with her as an 18 year old you think
that this girl is your [ __ ] world you
know
it's your very first girlfriend and you
think that she's gonna be everything
you're married all this other [ __ ]
and I felt like I wasted the most amount
of time with her and from that point on
I said when you know fundamentally
things aren't working you got to learn
how to cut it out
so if and I think I made a did a good
job of that I didn't really date around
I dated around a lot but I never stayed
in committed relationships a lot did the
commitment itself scare you even if you
came again some came up with someone
that like you you enjoyed oh no it was
somebody I did not enjoy it I would
leave him right I don't know if that's
actually a commitment issues yeah
because usually the way I think of
people with commitment issues as even if
it's someone that could be good for them
that the commitment itself to stay
together and work through [ __ ] is
tearing yeah because I was I think I'm
very not typical in the sense of even
though a lot of my guy friends were like
this I was never scared of [ __ ]
one-china like I wasn't scared with one
one vagina for the rest of my life you
know it's like a Russell's Peter the
Russell Peterson he was like one giant
like I'm not scared of one China like I
hey so I was never scared of like oh if
I settle with this person y'all never
get to have another first date or [ __ ]
somebody else again I never really had
that so it was more like if I find
somebody that I really [ __ ] with for the
rest of my life I like that because I
like monogamous relationships because
there's that singular support that you
get for somebody that knows you inside
out I love that whew so for example when
we first didn't yet I I don't realize
that excit but I do have anxiety it's
because for me personally I don't like
labeling things because it feels very
defeating because it feels like if I
label it this then I'm stuck with this
ailment so I just deal with it as if
it's an individual problem and it'll go
away it'll come back that's how I
mentally deal with my [ __ ] but I have
anxiety issues so when things are in
disarray and not in order
freaks me the [ __ ] out I like being in
control things that's why I don't like
smoking weed
I hate smoking weed because I'm not in
control of my [ __ ] when I'm drunk it
feels like I'm in control even though
I'm not that's why being drunk I love it
so that's the difference but when we
were first moving in here things were so
[ __ ] cluttered and [ __ ] up I got
really I started freaking the [ __ ] out
and I was getting pissed and I was just
dropping f-bombs all over the place and
then she was just like you know what
let's just step outside we're gonna go
walk around you're gonna calm down and
when we come back in I'm gonna close
this door or leave it closed we're going
in the room wash up and just go to sleep
and so but I didn't want to and no she
goes no no just relax and you grab my
hand walk me outside as I'm walking out
cursing throughout all of Glendale you
know just [ __ ] ask [ __ ] chef
don't fit in this corner what's that
tape measure for that tape measure said
it was gonna fit but guess that tape
measures off [ __ ] Chinese people and
their [ __ ] janky ass [ __ ] I knew this
[ __ ] was made in China probably Vietnam
maybe in Korea [ __ ] all this [ __ ] you
know I'm just rambling on and then I
come back I calm down and next morning
I'm like oh [ __ ] if she wasn't here I
probably would have been up all night
trying to make this thing work because
she knows me very well and that's that
type of support that I like about
there's this great feeling that you get
when you meet somebody new when you date
is super exciting it's [ __ ] fresh but
to me that's like buying shoes or buying
clothes it's great when you first have
it but after a while it just that
novelty goes away right I find the most
exciting part for me like you know as an
adult now when I started dating it was
it was exciting that that's what's
exciting to me is when that [ __ ] wears
off yeah and it's like okay are we
actually because what I'm looking for it
you know
next I'm I want one partner and I'm
looking for like that relationship and I
always you know it's like you want that
for me my experience has been like you
know like it's all exciting and whatever
in the beginning but like when that [ __ ]
wears off and it's like okay day-to-day
life like how do we work with each other
throughout these you know when things
aren't so fun and for
sure whatever yeah like that's that's
the stuff that I find exciting just good
but I'm a relationship person and so
yeah I'm definitely relationship person
too
it's it's nice man and when I was it's
weird because I was really scared to
move in with her yeah first time yeah
and took four years I I avoided that
[ __ ] like the plague around that I think
it's just I'd like living with my
friends and we already had this great
synergy going on you know cliff and all
them and it was it was fun but I feel
like it would with your girlfriend
interrupts what was going on with your
relationship like you like adding that
new it was like a you know I don't know
when I look back on it I think the fears
were really stupid I think I just was
like dammit I wake up and look at this
[ __ ] face every day is gonna be the
wedding yeah before we moved in I was
like I gotta wake up at this [ __ ]
place every day but I I would just you
know were we compatible living together
and we're gonna fight more and it turned
out that since we moved in together we
fight way less yeah because we're not
communicating through a [ __ ] phone I
could we could talk it out and I could
see her intention through her face yeah
so now it's like or even for her it's oh
he doesn't really mean anything by it
look at his face he's just joking yeah
she still gets hurt more than I do
though I'm not allowed to joke too much
she says you're not funny at all and I'm
like well that's how do i how do I make
my living [ __ ] I'm not funny at all she
does she hates it when I could I tease
her a lot yeah that's just how I am I
like I like teasing and Joe I think he
keeps things fresh yeah but she [ __ ]
hates it she's sure at a certain point
it gets [ __ ] old yeah
but she's done though because she says I
do stuff that's not even anything for
example she was in her bathroom I come
in and I go cleaning whoa what the [ __ ]
so don't scare me like that I said
cleaning question mark she goes it
sounded like you're a Chinese ghost
uh-oh
little racial there for an Asian person
she thought I came to said hello I just
said cleaning she's just scared of me as
she's sitting on the bathtub just Oh
[ __ ] that ugly huh yes it's kind of
crazy but she says like I [ __ ] around
too much I'm like that's not even me
[ __ ] around I just came in cleaning a
question mark she's a funny girl though
I think if I did if I wasn't with her I
don't know who I would be with because
I'm a very eclectic person I'm very
weird and she allows me to be weird and
she's very weird - I need somebody to
let me be me yeah I can't I can never
change that like my parents can beat
that [ __ ] out of me and yeah the person
I'm what there's not gonna do that
either that's important for anyone
that's the bottom line like whoever
you're with has to be they can be
themselves you can be you and we have to
love it they have to love it they don't
want to change anything about you you
know you can grow together but it's like
you have to accept that person for every
part of themselves let me ask you
something yeah where do you clip your
nails it is what do you clip your
fingernails in like where in my house in
your house where the [ __ ] do you clip
your fingernails see it's not weird I
did - oh okay I don't but I'm not
allowed to anymore legit that was
probably I was thinking like is this a
pillar for me I'm not allowed to anymore
because I like doing it in the comfort
of my bed and I'll catch it and take
Megan or something I always get a paper
towel and I lay it right and then I and
then I do it and then you can like and
then I just place the ones that go off
that's what I used to do and she's like
that is [ __ ] disgusting
she goes you need to go do it in the
bathroom I gotta stand up and do this
I've never done that
I've never stood up and [ __ ] I said
well how did you cut your toenails then
she goes you put it up I was like are
you [ __ ] kidding what is that a
furball
yes she does yeah she does everything in
the bathroom if it has to do with like
grooming of a snake but I mean that
makes sense to me now I'm wondering
about that yeah she won't let she will
not let me cut my nails anywhere I have
to cut my nails in secret now I have to
do it in secret she's all your nails
look up where did you do it outside in
the bathroom and I lied to you and you
wouldn't know the [ __ ] difference how
about that those are the things that I
feel just that's like that's something
that came up when you guys moved in
together for sure yeah the [ __ ]
toilet seat up thing [ __ ] too that's you
she didn't like it being upright no she
[ __ ] hated it and we still fight
about it till this day
disgusting and I [ __ ] hate that [ __ ]
so much especially like if you bring
someone over to your place and then they
leave it up like that's that pisses me
off so much um why is it any more
disgusting if the toilet seats down
here's my theory on it and our
friendship depends on the store if you
have to you as a man have to lift the
seat in order to do what you need to do
right so then [ __ ] finish the act and
put it back down okay why do I as a
woman when I go into the restroom have
to finish what you started well why do
finish what you [ __ ] start about this
why do i as a man just to take a [ __ ]
piss have to constantly lift it up and
put it back down who made up this rule
like then don't lift it up just then
then you're gonna have pee stains all
over and I can wipe it off working as
for us like wipe but that's a part of
who you [ __ ] are okay you're a man
and this is a part of being a man we
like there are things that we have to
deal with that we don't you tell that to
Caitlyn Jenner how about that how about
that okay no the guy I'm dating now he
puts the seat down and it's so she made
this rule now she goes fine if that's
the case and that's your argument she
goes we had to put everything down the
top and the thing so now when we use the
bat that we both had the both oh because
you wanted to be equal yeah now she made
that rule and I
[ __ ] hate that rule that rule even
more than the other one even though it's
a really good compromise I hate it oh
wait what is it why would that be a
thing to put you know what the reason
why I say it makes more sense for me to
keep it up is because I pee a lot more
but if you have here it's a part of you
having to pee is having to put it up so
finish the app finished the task put it
down that's a part of your task to pee
but see now we're doing the chicken and
the egg thing who was the first one to
use it boom in your [ __ ] a summer
chicken or the [ __ ] egg alright so
maybe I am finishing my task cuz it was
up in the first place
chicken or the game no but it shouldn't
be up in the first place it's a woman
saying this not the automatic setting
for a toilet should be that the seat is
down the automatic setting for a toilet
is that both lids are down that's how it
starts I wouldn't be I would not be
against that God you guys make me sick I
just hate that adjustment so it's one
idea it's but to have it up it's [ __ ]
gross it's gross is the word cuss it's
disgusting
alright toenail clipping in your bed
girl there's just like shards as your
dude lays in here slicing my thigh oh
that's my big toenail the boomerang he's
gonna find out when you watch it
scratches on my back oh my god summer I
guess that makes sense that was one of
the bigger adjustments too and I also
found out that even though I'm a sane
person how clean I am does not match how
clean she is she's way cleaner than I am
oh really cuz she thinks I'm a [ __ ]
garbage can and I'm like dude this is
pretty clean yeah but you like do you I
was having this discussion with my
boyfriend like he doesn't like to clean
surfaces like he's super tidy and
everything's always like clean and put
away but he doesn't like to
clean like the surfaces it's better I
would rather have somebody clean a
surface than man tidy because it's
disgusting the other way around
you have to clean [ __ ] yeah well no he
hires someone to do it that's fine but
that's even better
but for me like I'm i tidy and then I
also need everything it's almost like a
problem like I need everything to have
no dust on it and so I'm always okay
look in LA there is a [ __ ] hard house
everything has dust here dude it's
disgusting oh I know I'm always cleaning
my place always well that's good I'd
rather have somebody clean cuz I can't
stand filth like yeah me neither it's
disgusting it's like a deal breaker
I made it a point when I was really
really fat that I wouldn't ever be the
fat smelly guy like I was gonna be the
fat guy they smelled surprisingly good
okay if I'm fat at least it was never if
I was born fabulous though and I know
why my other fat friends they always
smelled like [ __ ] and I'm like I cannot
be one of you fat people it can only be
this fat person where a girl hugs me she
goes you smell great I'm like damn
straight I do I wouldn't I would keep
like extra shirts in my car because I
get extra sweaty and I was procession up
yeah I sweat so [ __ ] much I sweat a
lot too but you know really yeah I do I
sweat a lot like it's it's a problem
like if I get even a little bit nervous
I do don't ever back me up in court to
flaws I tell the truth ah I told the
truth immediately when I'm nervous and I
sweat immediately when I'm good don't
you ever I'm so glad you two grow up in
the hood everybody with us what's wrong
with you [ __ ] around the neighborhood
how could you I wouldn't tell cop [ __ ]
even though it would benefit me yeah
yeah I know I mean if I can can't stand
them but at the same time I'm like the
first one I dial
oh we're no longer friends
toenail clipping toilet seat down snitch
this is wrong with you did see this is
why I bring people on this podcast just
like a finally really are you [ __ ]
snitch somebody that's definitively
stitching it's like shady shits going
down and like get it out of my street
even though it's Waveland know how bad I
am I'm gonna say this on the podcast and
people will probably judge me for this
in Glendale the first few nights I was
laying down in bed and I heard a woman
screaming at the top of her lungs she
was like get away from me get away from
me I woke up I said she'll be fine and
then the next day I heard the same thing
get the [ __ ] away from me I told you to
leave me alone I woke up and I said this
[ __ ] better shut the [ __ ] up but I
sleep and I'll go back to sleep now day
three day three she was screaming if you
come near me I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
and I said you know what it's time for
me to call the cops serious well she's
defied the first two days so I looked
outside and I was like this person is in
serious trouble look outside it was a
lady with the shopping cart screaming at
nobody she was literally the shopping
cart say don't you you you [ __ ] leave
me a lot of [ __ ] kill you and it was
a lady with the shopping carts with
nothing inside it screaming at nobody
walking away and you could just hit her
scream just get weaker and weaker see my
instincts were right I said that woman
doesn't need any help
I'm the first like if I but if you hear
something like that I'm calling the cops
immediately you're a good person yeah I
ignored that woman you know why cuz I
believe that women can take care of
themselves and I said you know what hey
I lucked out that was a crazy you know
uh people always think that they'll do
the right thing when when [ __ ] goes down
but Jesus because you never been in very
situations I was at a Jamba Juice and I
saw somebody get pilfered all right
mugged fever eat in George in front of
Jamba Juice and in my mind when I see
these scenarios in my head this is what
I would do
somebody starts doing that [ __ ] I go
stop sir
I [ __ ] karate chopping in the neck
full somersault over him
uppercut him take him down and I say a
really cool line I've been waited to say
with my Winnie the Pooh I put his arm
behind his back to the point where his
hands touching the back of his neck and
I cranked on it and I was like no Jamba
Juice for you today something like that
but then what happened was this guy goes
hey takes a [ __ ] and I go oh that
happened like a few seconds late I'm
like oh [ __ ] he got robbed register in
the moment those things don't register
there was like a phrase where somewhere
when when crazy things happen to you
outside of your norm your brain tries to
rationalize it first and then something
happens and that's what that's what
happened to me because I was trying to
figure out like oh are they friends do
they know each other which didn't make
any sense because the guy was like this
crazy homeless dude and Jack this [ __ ]
and ran in my head for somebody I was
like oh that must be like his cousin or
something yeah yeah yeah you know yeah I
mean it's like that fight-or-flight
thing and you freeze on flight on flight
for sure if we're walking outside
somebody's bugging you you best believe
this is I'll tell you what's gonna
happen you're like my friend David knows
my tie and then you turn to the left and
you just see this cartoon cloud I move
so fast when he is just suspended in air
and then it drops that's what I'm saying
like I remember dating some girls - back
in the day where I think after my very
first girlfriend she was such a sweet
little hippie dippie girl I wanted to go
for the exact opposite so I was like you
know I'll date some of these ratchet
hood women and they were just a little
too aggressive for me
because you know we would go out
clubbing and [ __ ] and you know when you
go out clubbing Sacramento there's this
place call
parla polari that place was [ __ ]
ghetto dude but there would be always
some kind of random altercation and a
guy would walk up and you know maybe get
a little handsy on them and for me I'm
just like what the [ __ ] aren't you to
say something on my babe look at him
they're so used to guys being like a Meg
get the [ __ ] off my woman full and I'm
like we just dating [ __ ] he's not gonna
hit you don't beat the [ __ ] out of me
though yeah I didn't like that that that
[ __ ] yeah it's like I'm okay off that
[ __ ] unless that guy's like half my size
Tom puck in that for [ __ ] that [ __ ] dude
yeah I don't like that I don't like that
I didn't like that part of going out
when I was going out when I was younger
that like [ __ ] weird ego thing if
someone's dancing with you and then
someone sees it or whoever you're dating
sees it and then they get [ __ ] weird
like that's I hate it I hate it that
part when you're young though you just
you're just full of testosterone and you
wanna you know you just want to piss on
everybody that's yours
you know like this is my woman and you
piss on an ankle [ __ ] I think that's
what guys did that's what it is though
they get really possessive when you're
young yeah I would I was like that too I
was so jealous and for the right reason
I got cheated on but you know maybe I
pushed it that way who knows right but I
yeah but like my first relationship was
so weird because I just I wanted to keep
her to myself yeah yeah you know cuz she
was like my prize girl or whatever
whatnot which I don't [ __ ] even know
why I look back and I'm like it's wrong
with you dude yes I'm your type but I
just it felt so weird having anybody
approach her and it it was almost like
in a personal attack on you which is
done which is personal issues that I had
yes my self-esteem is low right so
because that girl was everything to me
when somebody would step in and enter
that world it was like you were taking
my everything so that's where that was a
flawed my part as a 17 year old kid was
just you didn't understand that that's
person as an individual and you should
be confident enough and in your
relationship to understand that that's
just is what it is and if that person
leaves whatever it's okay then maybe
okay if you don't think about that when
you're a kid I know like I dated this
girl in the first month
life i'ma marry this girl with my
[ __ ] $12 in my bank account my bag of
Skittles you [ __ ] [ __ ] it's so
terrible yeah yeah oh [ __ ] we are here
now are in well that's that's the
podcast right there guys well guys we
learned a lot today we learned about
past relationships I think this is this
is what I like though there's a lot of
like gems that in life lessons that
people had that people don't [ __ ]
realize you survived yeah hey I don't
know him but [ __ ] him you know grow up
in the hood because I always got a
backup the homie no matter what dude
what's his name [ __ ] Peter I bet you
were a habitual masturbator weren't you
you just masturbated excessively all
over the house she would have to wash
your clothes and that [ __ ] was stiff for
no [ __ ] reason habitual masturbator
Peter Davis whatever whatever dude I bet
you would [ __ ] steal her flat iron if
I could flatten out your pubes pubes boy
[ __ ] it Peter I don't see I'm good I'm
good at breakups like when somebody
breaks up no I back you up all the time
hey I don't have I don't have [ __ ] bad
I'm not I don't have bad breakups or I
really try not to I like to [ __ ] move
on be positive like you're good I'm good
no like [ __ ] damn your type not me I
was the worst upon them no I know
never I got some no no I like cope with
things because if we break up I'm like I
pray that you meet somebody that breaks
your heart
oh no I I genuinely genuinely I'm like I
hope that you meet someone that's like
amazing she accepts you for who you are
and like you know and that breaks up
with you after they've got something
better that's how I do it that's how I
do it I have to I have to it makes me
feel better
we have a [ __ ] you Peter alright just
waking up every day huh what do you do
huh Jack like a [ __ ] loser just
breathing in oxygen all the Earth's
oxygen you don't even deserve it what
else do you do I bet you Rob older women
huh
stupid ass what did he do that made you
mad tell me right now but you didn't
support her dreams huh these things are
not true and I would never [ __ ] know
what no we're a paedophile I got your
back what guys this podcast you guys
could catch us on every single audio
platform on iTunes give us that five
stars summer work and they find you
[Music]
she's not on Twitter you'll be granted
Twitter though you'll be fantastic at it
yeah yeah thank you guys for listening
and watching and we'll see you guys next
time and [ __ ] Pierre so hard in the butt
[ __ ] flat booty what did you sit on
huh you said nothing you have no but you
sit on your tailbone every day reading a
Bible that you can't even read because
you can't read dummy [ __ ] I got you